bonjour madame après-midi bienvenue à
l'émission les feux de forêt frappe et
frappent fort encore à plusieurs
endroits au pays au Québec il y a deux
réalités celle de la région de Sept-Îles
où les conditions météo donnent un peu
d'espoir avec de la pluie des
températures plus fraîches aussi l'autre
réalité c'est celle de l'abitivité
médicament ou le temps sec Nogue rien de
bon plus de 150 incendies sont en
activité au Québec une trentaine sont
combattues en ce moment c'est qu'il y en
a beaucoup des feux mais aussi des
ressources limitées d'habitude des
pompiers d'autres provinces viennent
donner un coup de main ici mais ces
autres provinces combattent elles aussi
des incendies en ce moment alors on a
fait appel à l'Afrique du Sud
l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande les
États-Unis la France notamment il y a
des discussions avec le Costa Rica le
Portugal et le Chili aussi ils viennent
de Trois-Rivières peut-être Montréal et
Gatineau Michel cochon
bravo votre équipe de recherche
merci Google
bonjour Merci Google bonjour à tous
Michel bonjour
sur le terrain ce matin à cette île
toujours délicat pour un politicien
d'aller sur le terrain on veut pas nuire
aux efforts mais on veut aussi montrer
que le gouvernement est là qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de ce qu'il a dit de ce
qu'il a fait ce matin mais je pense
qu'il faut saluer toujours ce genre
d'initiative mais vous avez raison de
dire qu'il faut pas nuire par contre aux
efforts de toutes les équipes qui
luttent contre ces incendies pour moi ça
va de soi mais je pense qu'on commence à
comprendre que François Legault devient
une habitué de situation difficile au
Québec c'est assez fascinant très
honnêtement de voir combien il y a eu
toutes sortes d'événements publics où
qui ont nécessité la présence du Premier
ministre
et François Lego c'est aussi sa
personnalité de bon père de famille je
pense qu'il a compris durant la pandémie
qu'il pouvait avoir cet avantage ou
cette atout pour juste faire attention
comme vous l'avez dit de ne pas en
abuser par contre je suis convaincu que
pour les populations locales de voir que
le premier ministre se déplace ça
certainement un effet encourageant un
effet de soutien et surtout pour dans ce
cas-ci les pompiers et tout le personnel
qui sont à pied d'oeuvre et qui
certainement ressentent de la fatigue
moi je vois ça honnêtement plus
positivement mais François Legault voit
toujours devoir faire attention à
comment il s'exprime je passe certaine
hier qu'il fallait qu'ils disent
carrément qu'il abandonnaient Clova de
la façon dont il le dit oui à de la
transparence c'est important que les
populations et la vérité mais tout est
dans la
l'intensité la délicatesse l'utilisation
du vocabulaire oui je sais qui est
revenu aujourd'hui
extrait je vous interrompre mais
écoutons monsieur le
le feu est trop intense pour qu'on garde
des avions donc malheureusement on ne
peut pas avoir d'avion là-bas ce qui
peut dire que il y a un risque important
par contre ce qu'on me dit c'est que
pour l'instant il y a quelque chalets
qui sont touchés mais que la plupart des
maisons sont pas touchées si le feu
réduit d'intensité on va pouvoir la
sauver va pouvoir retourner donc je
pense que il faut être honnête avec les
gens de clos vol
on m'avait dit que Clova elle est y
passer donc j'ai relayé cette
information là mais vous vous dites
qu'il aurait dû aujourd'hui c'est très
bien très bien les explications c'est
très bien hier c'est on abandonne
peu importe le nombre de personnes mais
le CDI nuance c'est des détails parce
que moi je pense qu'il faut avant tout
saluer tous les efforts de planification
de coordination de du gouvernement dans
son ensemble du ministère de la Sécurité
publique moi je lève mon chapeau très
très haut à tous ceux qui sont impliqués
de près ou de loin dans deux extrémités
complètes de la province il faut pas
l'oublier on est complètement à l'aise
on est complètement à l'ouest il y a des
défis d'organisation et je pense qu'on
peut dire en fait certainement leur
offrir toute notre soutien et nos
encouragements absolument c'est pas un
travail facile non plus pour les
pompiers des forêts pour les gens de
l'AR Mée aussi qui sont appelés là puis
tout ceux qui combattent ces incendies
de forêt parlons de François legoyer il
a fait un lien entre les changements
climatiques et ce qui se passe en ce
moment en disant il va y avoir des ça va
être plus fréquent ça va être plus
extrême aussi il faut peut-être penser à
se préparer ou à planifier vous parliez
de planification de se préparer écoutons
François Legault aujourd'hui encore
ce genre de questions là comment on
protège nos municipalités importantes au
Québec donc il y a des questions à se
poser puis évidemment oui on peut dire
que les changements climatiques amènent
une nécessité d'investir dans ce qu'on
appelle l'adaptation au changement
climatique donc oui c'est des choses sur
lesquelles on se penche actuellement
en particulier sur les réseaux sociaux
qui disaient en exagère c'est pas les
changements climatiques c'est une
situation contextuelle particulière
monsieur Legault lui dit ben là faut
peut-être voir un peu quand on commence
on se prépare mieux vous êtes de quelle
école vous Jean-François
moi je suis l'école la lucidité je veux
dire on a été après été ça soit au nord
ou au sud des feux de forêt record alors
ceux qui pensent que c'est pas la crise
climatique
je pense qu'ils ont un problème de
difficile d'attention très grave et
écoutez c'est la nouvelle normalité la
nouvelle normalité c'est que de mai à
octobre dans l'hémisphère Nord ça va
être la saison des incendies pour des
décennies à venir et donc ça ça signifie
que évidemment qu'on devra augmenter
considérablement les budgets qui sont
consacrés à prévenir et à lutter contre
ces incendies et je vais vous donner une
suggestion de savoir d'où pourrait venir
l'argent
cette année comme l'an dernier le
gourmand fédéral va donner 10 milliards
de dollars de subventions à l'industrie
pétrolière je propose un monsieur
Trudeau à Monsieur Guilbaud d'annoncer
que ces 10 milliards vont être plutôt
versées dans la protection des forêts et
la lutte contre les incendies
deuxièmement on a appris la semaine
dernière que c'était une année record
cette année pas une année record
seulement pour les feux de forêt une
année record pour l'investissement dans
l'industrie pétrolière et gazières
canadienne 40 milliards de dollars pour
étendre étendre augmenter la production
des hydrocarbures qui réchauffent la
planète qui provoque les feux alors si
on voulait être sérieux on annoncerait
immédiatement le gel de toute nouvelle
exploration et exploitation pétrolière
sur le territoire Canadiens ce qui est
demandé par le GIEC et ce qui est
demandé par
l'Association internationale de
l'énergie depuis des années et
finalement on serait ce que d'autres
États font c'est à dire se mettent à
poursuivre en justice les compagnies de
pétrole qui pendant des décennies en
financé des études bidon disant que le
changement climatique n'existait pas
n'était pas causée par l'homme et
n'était pas posée par les hydrocarbures
vous y allez avec le bazooka et le tank
[Rires]
forêt ne nous donnent pas le
l'électrochoc nécessaire pour essayer de
préserver les forêts de la prochaine
génération parce que là même si on
arrêtait immédiatement tous nos gaz à
effet de serre les forêts de l'approche
la prochaine décennie vont être brûlées
là si on arrêtait maintenant c'est pour
les forêts dans la décennie suivante
qu'on a géré
Dimitri vous pensez quoi de la
suggestion de Jean-François mais tout
suggestion d'arrêter quoi que ce soit en
même temps veut dire on le remplace avec
quoi donc ce que Jean-François propose
c'est on arrête la production à
l'extrait d'extraction du pétrole mais
mais comment est-ce qu'on va
conduire nos autos comment est-ce qu'on
va voyager comment est-ce qu'on va
chauffer nos maisons comment est-ce
qu'on va vivre Jean-François encore une
fois le topi puis les grandes
propositions
j'ai dit si tu veux répondre à mon
argument répond à mon argument c'est de
geler toute nouvelle exploitation
pétrolière c'est pas d'arrêter la
production actuelle
donc continuer avec les niveaux actuels
malgré le fait que la demande augmente
malgré le fait que il n'y a pas encore
une alternative
c'est c'est
quasi
elle est où donc on arrête de conduire
nos autos demain matin on conduit tout
ce que tu veux des feux de forêt pour le
reste de ta vie c'est ça la première
question est-ce que tu veux dire pour le
reste de ta vie c'est ça que c'est moi
ce que je te dis c'est que
on ne peut pas tirer profit de ses
crises et de ce type écouter je me
souviens j'avais 6 ou 7 ans puis chaque
été j'allais en Grèce parce que ma mère
travaillait ici donc les étés je dis
chaque été en Grèce les feux de forêt en
Europe par exemple vous êtes familier
avec l'Europe comme moi les feux de
forêt en Europe les gens s'attendent
chaque été il va y avoir un paquet de de
feu de forêt je ne dis pas on ne peut
pas
non l'Australie a failli brûler au
complet il y a trois ans non mais c'est
la réalité
il y a pas d'augmentation des feux de
forêt dans le monde parce que je vous ai
dit
ce n'est pas ce que je vous ai dit ce
que je vous dis par contre c'est de
proposer et de dire on arrête la
production pétrolière où on arrête
d'augmenter la production pétrolière
avec respect ce n'est pas la solution
non plus
c'est c'est comme dire à partir de
demain matin on est plus capable de
chauffer nos maisons
est-ce qu'il y en a une solution pour
vous
mais je pense que premièrement
finalement puis on parle toujours de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et je le dis je le répète il y a
personne qui est crédible là-dessus
mettre en place des taxes sur le carbone
ils disent ils vont faire si ils vont
faire ça mais les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre continue à augmenter donc
à un moment donné il faut des plans
réels des plans crédibles et des plans
de transition pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre sans nuire à
l'économie cette fameuse transition qui
qui a lancé commencer et on l'attend
toujours
est-ce que les feux de forêt ne nuisent
pas à l'économie les villages qui
brûlent absolument
Jean-François mais je vais répondre
exactement à ta question ok si on fait
ce que l'ONU nous demande les
scientifiques nous demandent
l'organisation internationale de
l'énergie nous demande c'est-à-dire
d'arrêter des nouveaux forages ce que ça
va faire c'est que le prix du pétrole va
augmenter et donc le prix de toutes les
énergies renouvelables vont devenir plus
concurrentiel est-ce que doit faire mal
de faire cette transition là est-ce
qu'on va prendre moins la voiture au
pétrole est-ce qu'on va peut-être
prendre moins de d'avions parce que ça
va coûter plus cher oui mais ça va
réduire les GES évidemment évidemment
que ça va faire mal alors il faut
choisir est-ce qu'on veut se faire mal
en consommant un peu moins ou est-ce
qu'on veut se faire mal en augmentant
les conditions de faire brûler nos
forêts c'est ça la question ok parlons
de ce débat hier Françoise le NPD a
demandé un débat d'urgence à la Chambre
des communes sur sur ce qui se passait
au pays bon on règle pas le sort du
monde avec ses débats là il y avait pas
énormément de députés non plus c'était
hier soir que ça s'est produit écoutons
Christina Michaud du Bloc québécois si
tu es un peu le débat
qui est pas rassurant c'est d'entendre
le Premier ministre canadien et de même
que le premier ministre québécois dire
que la situation actuelle risque de se
prolonger peut-être tout l'été ça va
devenir une situation qui est anormale
mais de plus en plus normale et les
autorités locales les provinces font un
travail extraordinaire je pense que le
rôle du fédéral c'est d'appuyer quand il
y a besoin mais si cette situation
devient de plus en plus normale à ce
statique est-ce que le fédéral de la
capacité à les ressources de venir en
aide aux provinces
voilà sur l'aide il y a des gens qui
disent ils devraient y avoir une cellule
dans l'armée spécialisée dans le combat
des des feux de forêt François Hugo
aujourd'hui a dit nous on veut garder
notre compétence là-dedans on veut pas
nécessairement qu'il y ait gouvernement
fédéral qui vient jouer dans cette
compétence vous voyez ça comment vous
franchement
avant tout je voudrais dire que le débat
extrêmement fascinant que Jean-François
est Dimitri 11 sur la présence du
pétrole le forage je convaincu que ce
débat là
ça fait chaud au coeur aux gens de lova
aux gens dans l'Est dans l'Ouest qui
sont en train de brûler le problème à la
base
ce qui m'intéresse moi de savoir au-delà
du fait que les changements climatiques
ont un impact sérieux sur le nombre sur
les inondations qu'on a vécues sur les
feux de forêt qui commence à être de
plus en plus nombreux est-ce que les
changements climatiques sont aussi la
cause de ces feux là il va falloir qu'on
analyse notre relation avec le feu au
Québec les foyers les parcs où on allume
des choses les erreurs humaines qui
partent souvent ces brasiers-là je me
souviens qu'en Alberta il y a certains
des gros feux ont été dus à des causes
de gens la rivière l'activité humaine
qui est ensuite exacerbée par la notion
des changements climatiques le fait que
c'est plus difficile de combat une fois
que le feu prend puis qui commence quand
on est un pays avec énormément de
superficie de forêt d'un océan à l'autre
et à l'autre et dans ce contexte là la
chaleur les chaleurs extrêmes la
sécheresse etc c'est c'est un site un
scénario pratiquement catastrophe qui
fait en sorte qu'il faut qu'on revoit
notre relation avec tous ces éléments de
de climat qui ont un impact Maxime
Bernier je peux vous avez vu son tweet
moi me renverser parce que lui ça fonte
là la faute qui donne
assez feux là c'est probablement des
terroristes
environnementalistes
aux gens pour
qu'ils que ces on va tu loin avec ça le
débat la suite d'urgence il y a
peut-être un petit peu avant son temps
il va falloir qu'on fasse un peu le
ménage ce qui s'est passé des besoins
que l'on a c'est un peu stocker de voir
que des feux là c'est pas d'hier la
Colombie-Britannique a brûlé il y a
quelques années l'Alberta spa nouveau
etc et dans ce contexte là d'apprendre
qu'on va former de nouveaux pompiers des
escouades spéciales parce que c'est
souvent dans des territoires de Première
nation qui sont un peu des missions pas
nécessairement les les ressources pour
faire face à ces événements-là
d'entendre mon premier ministre il faut
qu'on s'occupe des villes importantes
c'est quoi une ville importante en
passant est-ce que toute ville et tout
être humain n'est pas important ou
est-ce qu'il parlait plutôt des
infrastructures il y a plein de choses
qui vont falloir qu'on analyse avant de
commencer à dire il faudrait que le
fédéral rentre avec ses gros sabots pour
régler toute la situation là
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI